Speaker 1: Let's now speak to some of those
very folks in our audience.
We do this on the Friday show.
We do it via discord.
You can find the discord at David Pacman dot
com slash discord.
That is the place to do it.
We are going to start today with john from
Connecticut.
John from connecticut, welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, can you hear me?
Yes.
Cool.
So my question is more along the lines of
why does it seem like so many people nowadays,
especially on the right, seem to have a problem
with any critical thinking, Like it's so hard
for people to understand, to like, you know,
look at a situation that they're not used
to understanding and they can't like, they
just immediately jump to conclusions.
Speaker 1: Two answers to that.
Number one, there are some people who just
have not been taught how to think critically,
and so they don't.
Right.
And in a sense, you can't blame them to a
degree because if you haven't been taught
something, how can you be expected to know
how to do it?
On the other hand, there are those on the
right who recognize that when people really
apply basic critical thinking and media literacy
techniques to right wing ideology, it very
quickly falls apart.
And this is why those who are wise to this
actually don't want critical thinking taught
in schools.
They realize if too many people start thinking
critically, it's bad for the Republican Party.
So it's a combination of ignorance and bad
faith actors and in some cases, maybe a combination
of the two.
Speaker 2: What do you think is more prevalent
bad faith actors or people who are just ignorant?
Speaker 1: I think among voters, the average
voter, I think it's ignorance.
And listen, the left is not exempt from this
by any means.
There is a lack of critical thinking on left
and right, and we could slice and dice it.
But I think that the vast majority of those
who aren't thinking critically aren't thinking
critically because of ignorance, not because
they are bad faith actors.
They've been sort of indoctrinated as a result
of not thinking for themselves in a critical
way.
And it's really an indictment on the educational
system and the media system as well.
Speaker 2: All right.
So the last thing then is what do you think
would be the best way to, like, talk to the
people who are more ignorant, that are kind
of easier to, you know, maybe give them some
evidence to hopefully change their mind on
that type of situation.
Speaker 1: The best path for the folks you're
talking about is actually not to give them
evidence.
It's to know how to use a gentle, empathetic,
Socratic method of questioning to get them
to say, Hey, maybe I'm not actually that solid
in what I believe.
So it's.
Where did you learn that?
Oh, how do you know that's trustworthy in
general?
How do you know what things are?
Trustworthy?
What's a good way of figuring out what to
believe?
That approach, rather than beating people
over the head with evidence, is probably going
to be more effective.
Speaker 2: All right.
Thank you very much, David.
All right.
Speaker 1: John from Connecticut, great to
hear from you.
Why don't we go next to Nicole from Utah?
Nicole, welcome to the program.
Speaker 2: Thank you so much to David.
My question this time is actually related
to what Trump has said in relation to the
Ukraine war.
Do you think he has any chance if he does
get elected, which is a long shot anyways?
Does he have any amount of chance at stopping
this war?
He claims.
Speaker 1: Listen, you will.
He says, let's go through it in parts.
Trump says he will end the Russian invasion
of Ukraine in 24 hours.
When he's asked how, he says, Oh, I'll talk
to them.
Pretty silly.
Pretty dumb.
The only way that I see that conflict as ending
quickly would be if basically Ukraine gives
up and Russia just takes over.
So even in the best scenario, it's not going
to end in 24 hours.
Now, does Trump have a chance at actually
ending it?
I think he does have a chance in the sense
that every every president has a chance.
The question is the detail of how you would
actually do it.
But sure, I mean, Trump has a chance.
He just doesn't have a great track record.
That makes me think it's highly likely.
Speaker 2: Mm hmm.
That's all I have for you today, David.
All right.
Speaker 1: Thank you, Nicole.
Nicole from Utah, Great to hear from you once
again.